guten abend ich muss heute plus mit
unserem live stream ich freue mich sehr
dass ihr dabei seid keine app wurde im
vergangenen jahr so oft heruntergeladen
wie tik tok über eine milliarde mal sind
es mittlerweile aber mit der zahl der
user ist auch die kritik immer lauter
geworden tik tok wird zensur vorgeworfen
die chinesische plattform soll gezielt
die reichweite von bestimmten inhalten
aber auch bestimmten nutzern
einschränken zum beispiel wenn es um die
proteste in hongkong geht oder auch um
videos von menschen mit behinderung die
plattform aber die wehrt sich gegen
diese vorwürfe
wenn ihr fragen zu diesem thema habe
dann position gerne wie immer hier unten
in die kommentarspalte und wir gucken
uns jetzt erstmal tik tok an warum die
plattform so erfolgreich ist und woran
worum es bei der kritik geht
[Musik]
willkommen in der welt von falco punch
diese welt heißt tik tok und ist die
wohl angesagteste video app bei typ und
er ist dort ein star falco punch hat
mehr als sieben millionen follower auf
der ganzen welt und ist berühmt für
seine besondere bildsprache auf tik tok
dies anders als andere plattformen dem
bereich weil es wirklich nur videos sind
keine fotos kein wirklicher feet in dem
sinne wie bei facebook beispielsweise
dass man ein status oder so zeigt iqdoq
teilst du nicht unbedingt ein leben du
kannst du dein leben teilnehmen will
aber es geht eigentlich im grunde nur um
kreative videos die duh teilen möchtest
um feedback zu bekommen beispielsweise
die clips auf tik tok sind wenige
sekunden lang aber unglaublich aufwendig
produziert was der 23 jährige auf seinem
kanal aufzeigt haben natürlich noch
nicht alles zeigen nur eine minute ist
halt echt wenig braucht ein video was
drei bis vier stunden soll dann schnell
marielle wartet bevor es tik tok
produzierte falco seine videos für
musical die app wurde von einer
chinesischen firma gekauft und in tik
tok verwandelt dass die daten nach china
gehen könnten davor hatte keine angst
mich damit abgefunden dass wenn über
meine daten irgendwo sind vor allem weil
ich eine person des öffentlichen lebens
bin weiß man schon viel über mich und im
endeffekt was soll man noch mehr über
mich wissen ich habe nichts zu verbergen
das ist tipptopp steht in der kritik in
die verbreitung der videos einzugreifen
clips über die hong kong proteste wurden
zeitweise unterdrückt und diese nutzerin
ging mit ihrem video viral indem sie tik
tok austrickste die wimpernzange jetzt
wieder weg und schau mit dem telefon
nach was gerade in china passiert sagt
sie und prangert die
menschenrechtsverletzungen mit der
minderheit der uiguren an live
zugeschaltet ist markus reuter von
netzpolitik.org guten abend herr reuter
herr weiter sie haben mit einer
verdeckten quelle gesprochen die für tic
toc arbeitet und mit den moderation
regeln dort vertraut ist wie genau
schränkt dann die plattform
inhalte ein und welche sind das genau
also die plattformen also die recherche
müsste schon seit august gemacht
zusammen mit meiner kollegin christopher
und die plattform hat verschiedene
varianten um inhalte einzuschränken also
es gibt erst einmal die variante 1
inhalt zu löschen
dass wir dabei gar nicht so häufig
angewendet dann gibt es die nächste
stufe wäre zu sagen der inhalt ist nur
für den user selbst sichtbar und die
nächst höhere stufe ist dann noch vor
feed oder lotterie comment das heißt der
inhalt wird quasi aus diesem großen
nachrichten aus dem krieg aus diesem
algorithmisch zusammengestellten viel
fern gehalten und damit sind video
eigentlich wie diese videos die davon
betroffen sind eigentlich von dem von
der großen bühne genommen und das kann
mit einigen inhalten passieren
für alle die tik tok es vielleicht nicht
selbst auf ihrem handy haben mit diesem
feet ist gemeint wenn man die app öffnet
dann werden einem ganz viele videos
vorgeschlagen und wenn man darauf landet
dann hat man eben die besten chancen
viele klicks zu bekommen und wenn die
reichweite eingeschränkt wird und man
dort nicht auftaucht dann heißt das eben
man erzielt auch keine reichweite
eventuell gar keiner wenn niemand
anderes die video sieht herr reuter
vielleicht kommen noch mal drauf
eingehen
nach welchen inhaltlichen kriterien denn
da entschieden wird also welche team
sind das denn die dann nicht gezeigt
werden
also musste also verschiedene zeitliche
phasen sich anschauen also im september
zu bis nach unseren erkenntnissen gab es
im september eine sehr große änderung
das war nachdem der guardian dort
investigativ berichtet hatte und vor
september also diese alten regeln waren
so dass man zum beispiel keine
politischen figuren nach machen durfte
man durfte nicht die polizei kritisieren
man dürfte durch das militär kritisieren
man durfte keine inhalte zu reise zu
demonstrationen machen da war eigentlich
politik komplett ausgeschlossen und
wurde eigentlich komplett auf dieses
otfried also nicht in den auf die große
bühne immer markiert wenn der politik
haben also politik weiß einfach nicht
gern gesehen das war die eine sache
andere inhalte die auch
die noch darüber hinaus gab es wurde
auch kritik an tik tok heruntergeregelt
also wenn ich sage ich mag diese app
einfach nicht oder ich geh jetzt
woanders hin dass wurde quasi zensiert
oder in der reichweite nach unten
gedrosselt genauso auch wenn man
konkurrenten von tic tac nennt also die
nennung von whatsapp was in den
moderation richtlinien als direkter
konkurrent benannt ist führt dazu das
video keine reichweite bekommen konnte
bis dahin
und sie sagen das war zu dem damaligen
zeitpunkt war hatte ich das jetzt in
irgendeiner form verändert also die
regeln die wir einsehen konnten die
hatten diese attacken tik tok also diese
kritik regel war dort noch gültig als
wir das einsehen konnten genauso auch
dieses konkurrenz nennung verbot und was
weiterhin auch gültig war oder
wahrscheinlich auch noch ist ist das
eine variante wie man inhalte die
proteste beinhalten können auch auf
diesen ort vor feed geschaltet werden
wenn in zukunft ein gewalttätiger
konflikt passieren könnte
das ist eine sehr gute paragrafen artige
darstellung das kann man bei sehr vielen
sachen sagen da könnte in der zukunft
mal irgendwann ein gewalttätiger
konflikt passieren dass es generell das
was uns aufgefallen dass bei diesen
moderation regeln ist dass das die sehr
vage formuliert sind das heißt es lässt
den moderatorinnen und moderatoren sehr
viel freiraum was sie denn zensieren und
das steht so ein bisschen im gegensatz
zu dem was facebook macht wo man
versucht eigentlich so das bauchgefühl
auszuschalten und wirklich so schema f
artig beispiele und und kriterien zu
haben wo dann ziehen wo daneben inhalte
gelöscht werden oder versteckt werden
und das ist bei tik tok sehr vagen also
diese ganzen moderation regeln sind auch
nicht sonderlich lang das ist das was
wir gesehen haben ist eine excel-datei
von und ein paar seiten eigentlich okay
hier kommen jetzt natürlich ein erster
kommentare und einer schreibt zum
beispiel bei youtube china gleich zensur
und das liegt ja irgendwie vielleicht
auch nahe dass viele denken na ja das
ist ja nun auch ein chinesischer konzern
konnte sie dagegen die erkennen dass das
da die chinesische regierung in
irgendeiner form einen einfluss hatte
auf die die zensur die tik tok dann
wendet also wir konnten natürlich anhand
der wir konnten ja nur diese materialien
einsehen und und mit mit der quelle
sprechen wir könnten konnten dabei nicht
sehen dass die chinesische regierung
jetzt direkt eingreifen und sagt dieser
inhalt muss weg sein aber mir uns kam es
auf jeden fall so vor als würde als
würde da ein chinesisches konzept von
meinungsfreiheit dann quasi global
angewendet werden
bis zu dem zeitpunkt ebenso kritik
aufkommt und dann diese regeln dann
geändert werden also das ist schon also
die direkte einflussnahme können wir
nicht beweisen aber ich glaube dass
zensur und und in china auch nicht so
mit mit unserem direkten weisungen
funktioniert sondern vielmehr auch mit
so einer schere im kopf wo leute frau in
so einem vorauseilenden gehorsam dann
einfach antizipieren was gelöscht werden
oder eingeschränkt werden sollte und man
muss dazu sagen dass diese inhalte
werden in also die fdp deutschen inhalte
werden in barcelona in berlin und in
peking eben moderiert also die
nachtschicht arbeitete theken und auch
hier in deutschland in berlin sind eben
chinesische führungskräfte also der
einfluss ist auf jeden fall stark dort
aber inwiefern eine direkte
einflussnahme der regierung ist das
konnte man nicht sehen
jetzt müssten muss ich mir sofort an da
kommen ja die ganze zeit neue videos
rein eins nach dem anderen
wie funktioniert das überhaupt gucken
die sich alle videos an das kann ja
eigentlich gar nicht sein
doch soweit will es verstanden haben
werden in barcelona alle videos wirklich
angeschaut die ab zwischen 50 und 150
views haben also ansichten haben dann
bekommen dort moderatorinnen und
moderatoren mehrere frames aus diesen
videos vorgesetzt die schauen sich das
video nicht anhören auch nicht den ton
die gucken erst mal nur so grob drauf
okay ist jetzt kein porno drin
oder was weiß ich also und machen diese
vorsortierung in berlin findet die
nächste review stufe stadt also die
zweite kontrolle die ist so bei 6.000
bis 10.000 video ansichten und die ist
dann auch eingehende also das ist diese
vorkontrolle in barcelona ist angeblich
wirklich da wird jedes video angeschaut
ich guck mal hier in die kommentare und
hier ist was ganz spannendes war
facebook com ihr schreibt patrick die
frage sollte lauten wie gefährlich ist
unreflektierter medien konsum tik tok
ist dabei nichts anderes als sämtliche
plattformen und daraus leitet sich ja so
ein bisschen die frage ab ist tik tok
jetzt wirklich schlechter als facebook
oder oder sind andere netzwerke besser
gibt es da unterschiede wenn es zum
beispiel facebook oder instagram oder
youtube geht beispielsweise also
generell lassen sich die ganzen großen
plattformen nicht gerne in ihre
moderation regeln und reinschauen also
das ist ja immer das problem dass man
wir haben jetzt neue große
öffentlichkeiten die sind die milliarden
menschen kommunizieren dort und das
ganze ist nicht demokratisch
kontrolliert also ich wir wissen nicht
nach welchen regeln des abläuft und
keine dieser firmen lässt sich da gerne
rein schauen wir sind also immer auch
irgendwelche whistleblower auf menschen
die eben sagen ich gebe das jetzt an
journalisten raus angewiesen und da
könnte man sich schon überlegen ob
demokratische gesellschaften nicht
irgendwie regelungen und
kontrollmechanismen schaffen dass man
das eben kontrollieren damit nehmen eben
nicht irgendwie die standards wie was
ich meinungsfreiheit oder irgendwie anti
diskriminierungs diskriminierungsverbote
dass die nicht einfach von so vielem
unterlaufen werden können und man das
als user eigentlich so gar nicht
mitbekommen
das ist spannend weil genau das was ihr
sagen da schreiben hier auch user hier
schreibt zum beispiel sarah dass es eben
blöd dass die netzwerke sich bei nicht
in die karten gucken lassen und wünscht
sich hier mehr transparenz
wir wollen das hier noch ein bisschen
mehr warten denn sie haben ja diese
woche aufgedeckt das tik tok nicht nur
inhalte verschwinden lässt quasi also
die reichweite einschränkt sondern im
prinzip auch nutzer unsichtbar macht und
zwar menschen mit behinderung menschen
mit übergewicht oder auch homosexuelle
und das gucken wir uns jetzt mal
nicht nur politisch ist der eingriff bei
tik tok spürbar videos von menschen mit
übergewicht wurden weniger gezeigt um
sie angeblich von mobbing zu schützen
genauso wie menschen mit behinderung das
was jetzt raus kam in bezug auf trick
dog ist insofern hochproblematisch weil
nicht diejenigen die letztendlich
menschen mobben sagen wir mal
sanktioniert und bestraft werden sondern
dass im vorauseilenden gehorsam menschen
mit behinderung von vornherein die
reichweite verwehrt wird diese erreichen
könnten hätten sie keine behinderung tik
tok wollte sich diesbezüglich nicht vor
der kamera äußern gibt aber per mail zu
das so verfahren wurde diese regelung
war nie für einen langfristigen zeitraum
gedacht und während wir damit gute
absichten verfolgten wurde und schnell
klar dass dieser ansatz zu weit gehend
war
aus diesem grund haben wir sie durch
eine neue differenzierte regelung zur
bekämpfung von mobbing ersetzt also tik
tok sagt sie wollte vor mobbing schützen
herter was halten sie von dieser
begründung naja es ist ein komisches
konzept wenn ich quasi diejenigen die
gemobbt werde unsichtbar machen um sie
vor mobbing zu schützen anstatt die
mobber irgendwie zu quasi zu treffen zu
bestrafen oder unsichtbar zu machen
also dass diese täter opfer umkehr hatte
ich für ein schlechtes konzept und auch
wundert mich schon auch wie man so
unsensibel als großes unternehmen sein
kann dass man nicht irgendwie also die
debatte mit menschen mit behinderungen
fordern seit jahren irgendwie mehr
sichtbarkeit und da jetzt zu sagen wir
wir blenden die einfach aus dann werden
die nicht angegriffen das kann keine
lösung sein
also das ist wirklich ja das ist kein
gutes konzept ich frag mich so ein
bisschen ob das nicht auch so an dem
gesamtkonzept von tik tok was eben diese
heile fröhliche hey alles cool welt ist
dass da menschen dann die irgendwie ein
entstelltes gesicht haben
die down syndrom haben dass die da
irgendwie nicht reinpassen in diese
heile welt und dass man sie dann einfach
ausblendet das ausblenden lief er so
dass die dann einfach gedeckelt wurden
da wird also die wurden
das als jemand als behindert oder
besonders verwundbar heißt es in diesem
moderationstraining markiert wurde hieß
es wird nur in deutschland gezeigt und
das wird gedeckelt und ab 6000 views ist
daneben vorbei und man kommt dann aus
dem ist wird nicht mehr im feed gezeigt
bei anderen netzwerken da gibt es
moderation regeln da geht es eher um
hate speech quasi menschen zu schützen
genau vor hass und nicht irgendwie ihre
reichweite einzuschränken
sie haben jetzt einen blick gibt es dazu
irgendwelche informationen hat ihre
quelle ihnen dazu was gesagt wie tik tok
mit hate speech umgeht geht auch gegen
hate speech natürlich vor also ist das
passiert schon und ich denke in dieser
mobbing sache es ist wahrscheinlich
deutlich aufwändiger eben diese ganzen
leute die irgendwie mobbing oder hate
speech machen zu moderieren als an dem
video selbst anzusetzen und das runter
zu regeln also ich denke da muss man
einfach mehr moderatoren einstellen
dafür und wahrscheinlich haben sie das
einfach nicht gemacht da kann man mit
geld sparen indem man dann menschen mit
behinderungen ausklammert hier kommen
jetzt in den kommentaren natürlich viele
kritische bemerkungen norbert schreibt
zum beispiel das scheint ja heftig
zensiert zu werden das hat nichts mehr
mit netzfreiheit und pressefreiheit zu
tun und es kommen viele die fragen
stellen und zwar richtungen was das mit
kindern macht einmal schreibt jemand
eltern hätten auch die pflicht dazu
schauen was ihre kinder machen und
stefanie zum beispiel facebook fragt wie
gefährlich ist dieses portal denn jetzt
für meine kinder quasi soll ich die da
eigentlich dran lassen und ich würde das
eigentlich ganz gerne mal noch mehr
warten denn es sind zwar kinder aber
sind ja auch erwachsene die das nutzen
ja immer mehr was für schlüsse sollten
wir jetzt daraus ziehen aus all dieser
kritik während ja gleichzeitig große
medienhäuser beispielsweise axel
springer oder die tagesschau jahr neue
accounts dort eröffnet
sollten sollte man es jetzt dort
abmelden oder ist alles eigentlich gar
nicht so schlimm
nein ich meine ich bin datenschützer ich
möchte mich bei so was ist eigentlich
ähnlich außer zu recherchezwecken an
aber ich glaube wichtig ist schon ebenso
eine aufklärung dass eltern ihren
kindern auch sagen hey das ist was die
was da passiert und was da passiert ist
und wie damit umgegangen wird mit
inhalten und das ist also ich finde
schon wichtig dass du darüber zu reden
was da passiert man es gibt noch andere
natürlich sagen was passiert könnte mit
daten passieren die eben dann vielleicht
auf chinesischen servern sind oder von
china kontrollierten von chinesischen
firmen kontrollierten servern das sind
noch ein anderer aspekt aber
grundsätzlich finde ich also das
problematische daran ist dass man so
eine neue art von informationskontrolle
sieht die eben auch niemand eine chance
lässt sich zu wehren also wenn ich
irgendwie wenn bei der einschränkung von
meinungsfreiheit muss ich ja quasi wenn
ein inhalt jetzt gelöscht wird dann muss
ich als nutzer die chance haben zu sagen
hey das stimmt nicht warum habt ihr mich
gelöscht es gibt keinen grund dafür und
dafür sollten eigentlich die deutschen
gesetze gelten wie wo meinungsfreiheit
endet und diese beschwerde ich kann ich
merke das ja gar nicht merken okay mein
video geht nicht viral ich habe nur 200
ansichten bekommen aber ich kann nie
irgendwie sagen hey leute macht das mal
wieder schaltet das wieder auf normal
und das finde ich schwierig daran weil
hier wird eine öffentlichkeit und eine
realität konstruiert und quasi mit
seinem mischpult mit pushen abbremsen so
hingeschoben wie sich das unternehmen
vorstellt und milliarden von menschen
sind dort also das müssen wir als
gesellschaft auf jeden fall diskutieren
und überlegen wie wir damit umgehen sagt
markus reuter von netzpolitik.org herr
reuter ganz ganz herzlichen dank heute
für diese einblicke die sie uns zur tik
tok gegeben haben und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch bei euch für all die
fragen hier kam auch einiges tatsächlich
zur datensicherheit dann müssen wir wohl
noch einmal einen gesonderten stream zu
machen und vielleicht hat ja auch
nächste woche wieder dabei dann ist
daniel hier wieder für euch da würde
mich freuen wenn ihr dabei seid
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann gefällt euch
vielleicht auch dieser hier da ging es
um die schattenseiten von youtube oder
der hier da ging es darum wie gefährlich
die checks sind oder ihr klickt einfach
hier und last ein abo für uns da das
wird uns freuen
[Musik]